lortie
tellement bien une demi heure comment me
frotter nombreux mais mon pote
le gitan veut dire que ces jeux se sont
enfuis et d'émotion quand il revit la
statue de la liberté symbole de la foi
américaine de plus pour la démocratie
dans vous demander quels sont vos
projets immédiats le deuil d'une jeune à
la
dernière fille fera voler mais alicia
pour retourner sa vieille dame en
prime elle n'avait pas
du
tout les combattre mérite d'être déclaré
en état le wali avait battu le record
des prix dépend du lac à cette occasion
le
chanteur parle donc debout elle s'est
perdue en eau chaude par hasard au
profane
en est un has been ans sur sap en
cuverie de la fête malgré les merci
heureusement fonds de secours et cramant
des voisins tous les agents ben voyons
abu l'arbalète
c'est
d'abord à l'esprit d'équipé exceptionnel
nous sommes ensuite à l'agencier
évidemment à la supériorité de matériel
par les ou des japonais des têtes de
l'art pour ce à quoi la différence entre
le relais il ne faut pas me l'ont
dit à la qualité de l'aviation ennemie a
décliné et votre mécano à celui-là lors
il est né avec tous les doigts dans le
nez chaque fois qu'on des collèges c'est
tenait du miracle
elsa le tarif douanier l'os fives ram
d'un titre à la gaîté jours dans londres
nous permettre à nous et aux deux
chambres les verts et solaise de la loi
votre appareil est déconstruit les
dettes j'ai peut-être mieux a peur non
pendant toute la durée de sa mission le
jeune aura nos voix ni son extra demande
extrêmement chargé allez salut visage me
tiens avons l'intention des bars s'il
faut draguer de manière convenable salut
c'est à dire que le lieutenant moderne
serait retardé le moment de goûter à la
tarte aux pommes fabriqués par sa maman
de revoir la fiancée qui l'attend est la
grande rue de son village où il jouait
aux indiens quand il était petit garçon
mais je peux répondre à sa place si vous
avez encore des questions à poser je
répondrais aussi bien qu'il ne peut le
faire